good morning john
i've been a little bit stuck recently i
think i've been stuck because
i often don't know what the right thing
is to look at like what's the right
thing to see i went on vacation to
seattle last week it was the first real
vacation i've been on in a long time it
was the first real vacation oren has
ever been on and we did a lot of fun
stuff it was very good
one of my favorite parts and he liked it
a lot too was just watching the ships
come into and out of the port oren would
shout whenever we saw a new ship coming
or going and we'd run to the window and
we'd watch the tugs push it where it was
going and then we'd watch all of those
containers that had who knows what
inside of them getting moved around the
port and get ready to be shipped inland
or had overseas and i can look at these
ships
and heat them burning 30 gallons of fuel
every mile they travel pumping co2 and
other pollutants into the atmosphere and
i can look at them and love them people
working hard to engage in the tremendous
collaborative effort of delivering for
all i know awesome socks or micro cosmos
microscopes i can look at them and think
that they are ugly i can look at them
and think that they are beautiful i can
look at them and think that they are old
and outdated i can look at them and
think that they are a tremendously
recent innovation i don't know what the
right way to see these things is i'm not
in crisis i just had a lovely vacation i
have lots of support but being 41 years
old in the year 2022 has not given me
the kind of clarity i expected from
middle age
if anything things have gotten less
clear as i have gotten older
i used to think that the scars we've
left on this planet and on each other
were purely the result
of
malice or evil or at best ignorance
but now i look at those scars and i
still see the ones made by hate and
ignorance but i also see a lot that are
just made by living by love by trying by
pushing maybe too hard too fast because
of hubris or maybe just because of
excitement and joy and hope and
community and mutual thriving and fun
i look around me right now sitting at my
desk i see things that have done harm my
iced tea bottle the chicken sandwich
that i shouldn't have bought the
websites that let us share with each
other and tear at each other
but i'm also surrounded by things that i
love
like my iced tea and the chicken
sandwich that i can't quit and the
websites that let us share with each
other and tear at each other i'm not
saying i don't think awful cynical
greedy people exist they do
some people carefully cultivate fear
like it's a crop for them to harvest on
election day we are surrounded by harm
and we are surrounded by aid we are
surrounded by joy and surrounded by
sorrow
i guess i do know now that
nothing gets done if there is no room
for joy i know that
nothing gets done if we only see the
harm and nothing gets done if we don't
see the harm so i don't know
which thing to see more
i don't know if i'm seeing the right
amount of joy or the right amount of
harm or the right amount of grief or the
right amount of aid
but i know
that i have to see both
and there is a way of doing this where i
see one and then the other and then the
one and then the other the horror then
the beauty then the grief then the joy
but that way of doing it doesn't seem to
be helping me get anything done so
maybe there's a way to look at the world
and see both at the same time
john i'll see you on tuesday
[Music]
you